this is our first viewing of Dragonball
Evolution clearly fan-requested because
we know very little about Dragonball
it's where we know very little and
deluxe we know like half the cast we
know team four star we know a lot of
people that make Dragon Ball and
spin-off so Dragon Ball and are all
wonderful people fantastic we just never
got into the show it just never grabbed
nothing no issues but with any of them
yeah done it for years people know not
oh no I
it just never grants like Harry Potter
just never never grabbed me but yes so
many people like want us to review this
movie because apparently this is such an
insult to Dragon Ball so by the time
this comes out you'll know like you know
we're doing across several people that
do know about Dragon Ball
so that'll definitely help us out but
yeah we're just gonna be watching this
as like pure noobs only watching it as a
movie didn't knowing very little about
Dragon Ball is so what is so what is
your anime background like oh I know the
B I know like Miyazaki I know Full Metal
Alchemist
he's like the anime nut he knows a lot
of the big ones I've seen over 300
animes series he doesn't know squat
about it and I watch more anime than him
and I don't know squat yeah here we go
Dragonball Evolution oh don't be just
like dude if this is directed by David
Lynch yes planet faced its greatest
challenge how to do a proper anime
adaptation group of brave warriors
created the muscle bah I am already lost
Eragon - I mean Dragonball Evolution
it's any standard anime plot once upon a
time there was some evil demon Lord
thing he was going to destroy the world
but
bunch of wise sages of some sort we're
able to seal it away until uh-oh it's
gonna bust that again but somebody who
would in the ways of the ancient secret
family technique passed now by the
generations can help save the world
again when this thing is finally
released
I have just described 50% of this type
of animal we really have the cartoon
gold sound effect Goku I don't even
watch this show and it just sounds so
wrong his name is Goku look one of those
guys doesn't look Japanese it's hard to
tell happy birthday it's a box it's a
Dragonball
I got it for 550 down in Chinatown it
was either that or a Mogwai Dragonball
so are we watching that new Power
Rangers movie I believe the one try come
on no is this a Dragon Ball this is like
Jem and the Holograms I didn't watch gym
but I know this is a gem
we'll make blood vessels pop out of
skull flight style change huh doesn't
begin to sum up my confusion the white
people are taking us over we're gonna be
replace replaced that's the only
Japanese you're gonna hear this I paid
good money this they kill Hitler with a
giant mecha
oh shit I shouldn't have dropped acid
before class oh poor kid I know his hair
naturally looks awesome oh no poor
Patrick and Shia LeBouf and his sons if
they did they would clearly name him
Goku he just looks like a Goku all the
other films about kind of nerdy dorky
kids and if you're anything nerdy or
dorky about this kid yet his hair is
naturally Andrew Garfield knows karate
sounds not only was a lady nerdy or
dorky I'm pretty sure he's 35
my spider dumb is going wild I know this
may be hard to believe but I'm actually
Asian in this movie what happened your
parents I don't know but my grandpa said
everything will be explained to me when
I turn 18 what did grandfather wear my
parents I'll let you know when you're
older but you know what he still made
him a cake and the dude still ran out on
cake gets burnt swear that's an asshole
you don't run out on cake I have to go
I'm sorry
let's don't skip there hmm Oh much time
left you can still have cake if I have
to see one more old mentor die in a
goddamn movie oh my god do they just
have a meeting place in the afterlife
like why do we teach anybody
we always daughter you it feels like I'm
watching like one of those CW shows
who's subjective urgent a small village
us has that lower budget quality it just
looks like he was constructed from
lesser meeting man
yeah grandpa couldn't help laugh at how
ridiculous this is from the a boy is
like you're gonna be wearing that before
this movie's over even from a traumatic
standpoint why why who's the idiot look
at it
who's the idiot I'm the one holding the
little orange ball that's his play
school on it sure you know this is a
horrible world building in fact that's
right the name of this town horrible
world building world building is world
dumping what you told me to come here I
just come in here ha ha ha movies tone
is amazing just amazing big blow so well
into each other do you have a Dragon
Ball she talks like Peter Griffin see
you have a dragon moment
why was my wish do you have a drag about
how she looks like that girl for about
Ernest saves Christmas I'm harmony star
this one Santa Claus come down you don't
need to be a dragon ball in anything
just go back to where you came from the
Sun comes out it's gonna be hot hot hot
everybody is acting like Christopher
Walken normally acts in any movie random
lines said hot wouldn't be able to get
this Dragonball wasn't being able to get
this dragon ball into the lava melded
with the right eyes it's worth like a
bajillion cannot toss it Ernie Hudson oh
my god it's not is this it is Oh such a
good actor being so many bad things did
I tell you about the Twinkie wait so is
it Goku or got to they got it wrong okay
cool you can do Tai Chi that's great you
have achieved something that literally
old people in China do every morning
and release shit I hope he doesn't know
House tried to blow that off I have to
practice you watch like Star Wars like a
really good anime and when they do these
sort of powers it's like well I really
want to like do that whatever I see then
this shitty movie is like well I would
have no interest in that whatsoever this
is literally boring me to watch and I'm
glad it isn't real you know my grandpa
always said in order to master my King I
have to be a one with myself
yep no no this sounds right coming from
that voice you know my grandpa we said
the wood master McKee every time you
light a torch you get to take one step
closer it's me that's how you master
your ki the vital energy force that
flows within you sacks before you master
your ki you must master your slog yeah
dude I am the keymaster are you the
gatekeeper just like shit I'm gonna have
to make good at this oh my god dodged
that bullet
he sets her on fire it's not that long
it's not even an hour
really so they honestly thought that you
could do like a Dragon Ball movie in an
hour and a half yeah sure that's like
still going it's like one piece it's
like a perpetual show generating machine
yeah for every one episode that's
released there are three more that come
out right afterwards I'm just carrying
this candle I believe you you know we've
seen that situation a million times in
movies and shows too when they had to
convince which one's the real one a you
thinking okay well what Swiss I got
doing this help me okay Roman I even try
and do something new with that oh gosh
not offended 7-eleven sushi faith in Who
I am or who you're not fans are really
it is so weird because I feel like if
this were an even bigger budget movie
finale would have been like 20 minutes
longer but I'm kind of great yeah one
wish will be granted
world peace no bring Hawaiian shirt guy
back maybe I can just bring people back
in general nope just this one guy funk
out a hair drink about a lush I know
what this is
my hair grew two inches taller that day
they'll throw a punch and it'll cut to
the end credits right before they have
each other watch watch watch yes fuck a
comment based hahaha see there's like
ecology at the end and credit sequence
or something it's fair to start to walk
in evolution nobody watch the other
direction as if any the fan stayed for
this and credits equal they might have
stayed just to throw more things at the
screen they wouldn't bought more popcorn
just so they can hold it cut right there
making soup and it's piccolo and it's
leave one is shocked I mean Jesus Christ
come on
whatever you like God did you see the
look on his face I swear you looked at
the camera for a second like you're
still here
like they knocked out the actor put him
in that just filming his contract is up
but you know filming it was just like
all cut wow that was really dumb not
knowing really jack shit about DBZ um I
feel like what little I got out of this
movie it's like I could just tell where
the giant cuts in the story were made
there was way more to piccolo there had
to be way more to pretty much every care
yeah here's the thing with a lot of
these big stories a lot of them do have
these tropes of like the old mentor old
mentor dies the young person has to go
on a hero's journey but then they also
add more they adds something new
something original a lot of charm to it
something vulnerable something strong
and these kind of stories like this in
Eragon and stuff they just do the bare
bone minimum like you know we'll just do
what everybody's done but not add
anything yeah pretty much as people that
don't really watch this show it was just
a dumb movie it's kind of a fun Mortal
Kombat annihilation it's like so
amazingly bad it's funny it was it's
definitely entertaining Lee bad it's
it's entertaining Lee bad but I if I am
NOT a DBZ fan if I was I'd be put if I
were I would have like taken a butcher
knife to the movie screen and been like
tearing it up that's about it and we
will see it
that's one way that
you